one local teen is hoping to make a  difference by creating a peer support  network it's called brooklyn's  therapeutic help she says the goal is to  provide an outlet for teens to talk  about many issues they may be facing at  home at school or in their social lives  she says having an online forum provides  another option to talk if they don't  feel comfortable expressing themselves  in person  they need like  support with anything like rather than  like support like talking to a friend or  like say like they needed like they  wanted help like  um  like  resolving like some like argument or  something going on between my friend  like i'd be openly talking about that or  if they just want to tell me about their  day like i'd be open to that  brooklyn says the idea came from her own  experience with mental health struggles  the website also has a link to other  coping skills and de-stressing options